jesus louisardo this will be his ninth
uh outing of the year the ninth start i
should say third though with the marlins
however coming in with a high era but
again now that he's we've been working
with mel stottemeyer a little bit we
assume that that will go down in rather
short order so that'll bring up david
body duffy he's at first with one out
here in the cubs half of the first
and david bode likes to look at that one
deep to left
gone david bodie a two-run homer cubs
laid two to nothing that's a good way to
start a road trip right there absolutely
your first step back you get into a
hitter's count that 1-0 count you're
just looking for something out over the
plate you're sitting dead red fastball
but what happens is you get something
that spins and it's up in the zone and
you just let your hands do the work
always dangerous to hang a breaking ball
to a dead red fastball hitter you can
end up paying big time and lizardo paid
for that one right there promoting
number seven on the year he has 31 rbis
cubs lead two to nothing quick start for
chicago that will bring up patrick
wisdom goes to the curveball there gets
the strikeout that's out number two now
when you work from in front you can open
up the strike zone just a bit wisdom way
out in front of a breaking ball and this
is a good breaking ball down in the zone
robinson churinos to the plate
hey gets the strikeout on the curveball
and for lizardo the first sitting ends
better than it began advert alsalai
we've become very familiar with advert
building off of a good strong
performance last time out slider sinker
guy a lot of sliders 40 of the time
mixed in the occasional four-seam been
working on that changeup and cutter a
way to offset his struggles against
left-handed hitters but a very very
impressive turnaround last time out so
looking to build on that mickey was on
the move in scoring position for jesus
aguilar
ground ball to third backhanded in a
long throw across the diamond a strike
from duffy to schwendell an rbi ground
down for aguilar marlins cut that
deficit in half they trail it two to one
ali very nice at bat for aguilar yes it
ends in and out but he works back from
the o2 count and gets the run home in
rojas job well done by aguilar jones
ruth marcus at the plate happened first
the one over to fargus there's a swing
and a drive toward right pretty well hit
back as dealer crews that balls in the
corner bouncing off the wall and
bouncing back toward the infield happ is
rounding third and he will score on his
way for a tripolis johneshui fargus cubs
lead three to one fargus going to the
opposite field taylor cruz got a little
too close to the wall ryan and it
bounced back past him and he had to
chase it down yeah gets a pitch out over
the plate does exactly what you're
supposed to do with the pitch down and
away he drives it to right field and you
talked about playing too close to the
wall combination of getting too close to
the wall and how hard this balls hit
that karim comes off there gets by de la
cruz and right field hap scores easily
and sliding in safely to third bases
fargus great job right here app with
good speed scored pubs lead 3-1 nobody
out sergio alcantara
this will get the run in deep right
center
chasing it is david cruz making an
excellent backhand running catch
waltzing in the score is fargus and the
cubs lead four to one sacrifice flies
sergio alcantara he just missed an extra
base hit yeah we've already seen two
good defensive plays out of de la cruz
and right field the ball and schwendell
in the first that he went back on and
this is a tough one it's a lot of
distance to gain he got after it got a
good jump on the ball but great job by
alcantara there to get the rbi get the
sac fly that really was an excellent
play by de la cruz brian de la cruz wait
spaces are loaded full of marlins 3-2
and this one is hit out to left field
this is the right size and the right
shape he comes back and it's a grand
slam
on the next
[Applause]
his first career home run on wednesday
his first career grand slam here tonight
how's the life being looked at by p.j
mainville david ross out to take a look
as well you see here just something felt
a little pull called the trainer weighed
it right away didn't like it last thing
you want to do is take a chance with a
hamstring and that leads to some sort of
arm problem so doing the right thing by
getting him off the field right-hander
dan winkler will take over on the mound
so they will be loaded again now louis
brinson will step to the ditch
brinson into left center field that is
down
one run is in here comes
[Applause]
well they're loaded again still only one
out
and now
carl is hit by a pitch winkler gets
alfaro now bring up alex jackson now
that one sneaks away from chirinos here
comes princeton he'll score eight
marlins have touched home plate this
inning second and third one out the cubs
now trailing 9-4 3-2 pitch
and alex jackson with a high fly ball
this one out toward left center field
this one's got a chance this one is gone
three-run homer for alex jackson 11 runs
in the inning it's twelve to four
marlins have lead off man on for the
third consecutive inning we're board for
jesus aguilar payoff pitch to aguilar
and this one is hit well the left
then it's gonna carry out for another
home run for the marlins
14-4 look at the fans pretty excited i'd
say so we've got the first two outs here
in the fourth inning facing david bodie
now who homered in the first
this one into right long run de la cruz
is gonna get there a sliding catch
have a night
brian de la cruz nicely done third time
tonight you can hang a star on a
defensive play by brian de la cruz and
oh yeah he said a grand slam tonight as
well
for the strikeout on a single dubs are
down by 10 here in the fifth inning with
one away and nobody on
here's a deep drive to left get out the
tape measure long home run for robinson
chirinos straight away left his fourth
this season and it is now a 14 to five
ball game but a leadoff single for duffy
and the cubs here in the eighth gonna
bring up the first baseman frank
schwendell 1-0
here's a deep drive to left center off
the bat of swindell all the way back
long gone get out the tape measure for
frank schwendell a booming two-run home
run and the cubs trail 14 to seven he
and have to turn around about
left-handed for the first time tonight
torino is hoping to score before the end
of this inning
deep drive right center by half get out
the tape measure again long gone the
clubs are getting back into the ball
game now they still trail by five and
keep fighting back never quit never give
up raviol ortega coming up as a pinch
batter the cubs still need three more
men to reach
he rips a ground ball off the glove of
aguilar down the right field line
schwendel is going to score on a base
hit by ortega
it's 14 to 10. here's chirinos
nothing in two with ortega off of first
swing
strike three
it's a marlins win 14-10
you